you should always think that there are
things that you must keep striving for
things that you haven't done things that
you would still like to do and that's
how that's how one's life should be
lived
Kirk played a lot of tough guys in the
movies but in real life he was known as
one of the most compassionate men in the
business I hate bullies I think it's a
very unattractive quality so if I do
intimidate people I'll just try not to
in the future but Douglas was far more
than just an actor he was also a
producer a philanthropist best-selling
author and proud father to his four sons
Michael was his eldest as I always say
if I'd known Michael was going to be so
successful I would have been much nicer
to him when he was young but I'm proud
of Michael but I'm more proud of how he
handles his success than I am of his
success in 1996 Kirk suffered a stroke
that impaired his speech but not his
spirit when we visited him at his home
in 2014
Michael actually crashed our interview
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
he celebrated his 100th birthday in
December of 2016
at a bash that included his family and
close friends anybody who's that any
more than this man has at 100 years old
[Applause]
his acting career spanned seven decades
two of his most famous roles were
Spartacus I do know that we're brothers
and I know that we're free and the bad
and the beautiful with Lana Turner who
gave you the right to dig into me and
turn me inside out and decide what
unlike many movies that I'd like to redo
but on the other hand there are certain
movies that I think yes I like them but
that doesn't mean that you don't you're
not constantly learning something and
that's part of the fun of it in 1991 at
age 72 he survived when a helicopter he
was a passenger in collided in the air
with a plane five years later he
suffered that stroke shortly afterwards
he talked about survival with Mary Hart
I've been in the helicopter crash
I had trouble walking I had a stroke and
Here I am I'm a program called
Entertainment Tonight so let's be
entertaining he was born
Essaouira daniel ovitch in new york to
immigrant parents my father was an
illiterate Russian Russian peasant came
to this country like millions of other
people
he earned three Academy Award
nominations for his acting but never won
as a performer in 1996 the Academy
presented him with an honorary life
achievement Oscar I see my four sons
they are proud of the old man his
marriage to his second wife and lasted
more than 60 years the family suffered
tragedy when son Eric died of an
accidental drug overdose in 2004
kirk was a man who was admired for his
generous spirit and open heart he deeply
loved his family often showing his
affection by kissing them on the lips an
old Russian traditional
[Music]